using opinions on this
where were you I'm not talking today
[Music]
someone okay if I don't someone else
will okay okay it's definitely fine you
don't have to put up with that one okay
thank you you're definitely right yeah
yeah I'm glad thanks
listen to me when I'm talking stop
trying to [ __ ] walk away from me stop
it
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't give me that [ __ ] okay
pathetic you're so [ __ ] pathetic
intense
my blood is hot
um right as you saw uh there were two
scenarios there uh one with a man mum of
a woman
what was the difference
and why was there a difference do you
think
with the way the public reacted
I think it's um
it's actually quite sad
um the difference is no one came to the
man's Aid
um there was a part where a lady had
well majority of the women
in that scene when laughing also
alongside with the men as well I kind of
think it's um
it's quite shameful to see that it's not
taken seriously although she was doing
exactly the same thing
in the reverse roles no one came to his
Aid no one thought it was anything
serious
it was um
yeah I guess it's a pure example of what
goes on in every day
do you think it's it's okay to hit dude
people generally think that Society
thinks it's okay for men to suffer from
physical abuse from women yeah
I believe so um I feel like people feel
like talking tonight
so like
it's not as deep as if a woman
was to hit a man yummy no
I think you're gonna have to run that
run that part again what do you mean all
right what do I mean yeah yeah do you
think Society thinks it's okay for
men to go through physical abuse because
um we saw there it was justified I think
I think the way it's seen is um if a
woman does it it's not seen as heavier
yeah and it's poor across like that
because you know they are deemed as you
know the Pharisees and they always ask
what did he do yeah yeah right there's
no questions asked on the other way
around yeah you deserve better than that
you know yeah like if a girl's going
crazy it's always like what did he do
what do girls always say what did he do
to make her yeah but now you're just
crazy I don't and one of the lines from
there I think was quite interesting is
that the guy came and said oh yeah you
deserve better than that you don't have
to take that but no one said that to the
man
do you know what I mean so it's like
what does a man have to take it I think
it's what's put out there a man has to
take it I think it's seen as now if a
woman does anything of that nature we
are
automatically by default expected to
accept that
because at the end of the day we don't
you know there's gonna be
tons of other people with the similar
kind of traits and it's not going to get
any better so we have to kind of be
content with the kind of treatment we're
receiving and this hope for it to
improve you understand and that just
depends on the kind of guy you are
um moral coding and I guess it's what
was pushed out there for the man to be
weakened right to accept it
to um I don't think it's weakened yeah I
think it's I think I think it is to for
a man to be weakened because at the end
of the day I don't think anybody should
be hitting anybody I think violence is
violence
I've had this conversation with a few
people
you know say oh we are the girls we
cause she's not as built as you a man is
built with muscle then I say okay let's
put a gun into the equation I know
that's a bit extreme but if someone
picks up a trigger you know a female
picks up a gun a guy picks up the gun
they both pull the trigger does the same
thing right yeah so if you go up to
Dwayne The Rock Johnson and you punch
him No One's Gonna Be Mad Or No One's
Gonna feel bad for you when you get
punched back
right yeah I don't think I'll be
punching him but yeah but that's what
I'm saying like girls like if the
argument is that the girls are weaker
like then you could say the thing if a
weaker man goes up to a stronger man and
hits him do we feel bad when he gets hit
back no but it's kind of weird because I
guess you'll be seen as bullying than in
the hospital what do you mean
because someone your own size if you're
saying a wee come on you know what I'm
saying if the weaker man picks a fight
with the bigger man um and then the
bigger man hits back nobody feels bad
for the weaker man because he picked the
fight but for some reason with women
it's not the same like if a woman picks
a fight with a man and it's hitting a
man but if she gets hit back people
it's because the type of way that we saw
if the man was to retaliate
if the man was to retaliate during that
time right it's a different board game
yeah but the chances are he's if I was
to punch you he punched me back you're
gonna hurt me a lot more I'm not
justifying here but but that is truth
you know you are the strongest sex so
I'm not saying that I should I'm not
gonna I don't go around punching men and
I wouldn't but because as a woman I know
that if I did and he hit me they're
trying to say is going to hurt me like
the domestic
but violence that statistics oh I'm with
you and I'm not with you
um you have a point but then I think
that you you spoke on a narrative of
your weaker because you're a woman yeah
yeah but that is that is biological is
he not uh
we could take the same example with
Dwayne The Rock Johnson like it's by
like he's huge biologically and so if a
skinny man picks a fight with a big man
and he punches back nobody feels bad for
the skinny guy of course but but
domestic violence over here a woman's
dying every three to four days that's
everywhere all right yeah no of course
but I'm talking about the UK so I don't
know what the opposing argument so well
most um domestic violence is unmutual so
both parties are hitting each other but
one-sided abuse is actually more common
for um men to be hit one-sided than
women to be hit one-sided
I've actually got some statistics for
domestic violence when it comes to women
and men
um against men um specifically because
I'm I've gone to the National Center of
domestic violence right and it actually
says this male victims to find a finding
was mirrored in an annual crime survey
for England and Wales which found a
quarter of all domestic abuse crimes in
2018 to 29 2019 were committed against a
male victim
in the same year 16 men died at the
hands of their partner or ex-partner
compared with 80 women the crime survey
stats also showed that 3.8 of men which
is equal to 786
000 were victims of domestic abuse in
2018-2019 so I'll be very interested in
that that video except having a woman
that was bigger than the man right do
you think that was done type cast like
do you think that was done deliberately
just to probably no I think they just
they just got who they could to play the
roles but it'll be interesting if you
had a woman say say Ronda Rousey right
Ronda Rousey bullying a smaller dude you
can't make the argument that if Ronda
Rousey punished you it wouldn't hurt
anything
how many women like that though uh yeah
well you know that's what that's what
I'm saying but it'll be interesting to
see to see how this logic lines up when
you have a woman that's more physically
imposing because I guess the idea with
that video is that the man is obviously
going to be this the more physically
dominant one right so he can take he can
take more and whenever he wants so he
can he can finish the situation and so
that's why it's more it's more so would
you say that is a would you say that as
a misandrous type of view no I think
it's just based on reality okay like the
guy like if he wants to beat her up he
could like he's not it's not like it's
not like she's physically stronger than
him it only changes if when you have a
woman he's physically stronger than a
man I'd like to see whether Society
holds that up on the same lens like
would that would that be bullying I
don't know could you say the woman
should like sustain more should be more
patient because the guy is weaker than
her and you know this that would they
put the same responsibility on the woman
to be the more mature more patient kind
of part of you know that that would be
very interesting to me so before I was
talking about Miss Andrea it means like
do you I'm saying do you think that the
societies become more misandrist yeah
absolutely because misogyny has spoken
about a lot isn't it like we speak about
misogyny men and misogynists you know
and there's a lot of talk about misogyny
um when it comes to the whole feminist
movement but I I can see from what I can
see I can see that misandre's kind of
taken more of a foothold now over
misogyny I can see men
women actually hate in men and hating on
men men are trash men are dogs men are
there something like that like
why are you smiling and laughing what do
you expect that it's a consequence of
misogyny that's where it comes from if
you take that out of the equation then
you won't get so I don't think it's as a
woman I know for well
uh it wasn't grinding meter hey man but
as you grow up and you see them act a
certain way then you're gonna have an
opinion of them I wouldn't go swimming I
wouldn't go swimming in Australia even
if there was one shark attack I wouldn't
go near it because I know the
consequences but yet as women we're
expected to to still
um trust men that that hurt us
okay what do you mean what do you mean
like what you said what do you what do
you see that bad deal that's so bad well
first of all I said about the domestic
violence and then I think if you look at
like women women do it too no no of
course that men ain't dying at the same
rates so well they can't who's to say
what do you mean who's to say I think
everything that we see is this is what's
given to us as fast we can't take that
as gospel do you know do you know women
have diets no suicide no suicide is is
one of the biggest indicators of our
suicide is relationship conflict or or
breakup so you know maybe it's not being
logged as domestic violence but there is
definitely abuse going the other way and
and that's a significant part and more
women hit men one-sided than men hit
women one-sided I I struggle I do
struggle with this like uh on this on
the websites that I've seen that women
are arrested more for domestic violence
than men even though they suffer more
and and like when in 2000 in 2010 2020
when 110 women died that year because of
that their hands are now 50 of those
deaths were Overkill which means they
killed them there was there was like
brutally kidding them long before that
long after that 110 in London
in the UK that's really not a lot one
every three days you don't think that's
right for the whole year so say from the
whole year yeah from the whole year so
from then to now so say at the
percentage of deaths is that that's got
to be less than one percent yeah do you
honestly think that a woman dying every
three to four days is not a lot I don't
think it's like
um I don't think it's like a pressing
like if it's not one of the numbers
because it's not one of the number one
ways people are dying here
so like like if if we're gonna talk
about if that if that's the big issue
like then we should maybe put obesity
why is it always fat people when that
alcohol is a drug and it's so normalized
but why is the default always fat why is
the default always fat it could be
alcoholism because because that can
because the stuff that self more people
die what I think what Paul's trying to
say is more people die each year from
self-inflicted things than something
that's been inflicted on somebody else
yeah that does make sense but it doesn't
excuse it do you see what I mean so say
so say when I wouldn't excuse it it's
just putting it into context yeah if you
take if you take a number like 110 out
of a country with like 60 million people
and try and make the case because that's
why well because you're trying to
generalize something about men if you're
gonna if you're gonna make a
generalization about men I want to see
is this prevalent among men is this
really common when you said 110 I'm like
well okay the UK is very populated that
doesn't sound like a lot of people and
when you put it into context but if you
put into context I don't think it's okay
I don't think you do but then if you put
it into context the same amount of women
have died this year right so it's one in
one every three to four days so say from
2020 2021 2022 if you multiply 110
that's free for a year that's close to a
year so our three years there was one
year where a woman was dying every day
that's mad will you put it like that
I don't I don't think it's okay but I
just if I had to guess if I had to guess
I would think that things like car
crashes and obesity would probably be
higher but they're self-inflicted so
that's on them I could walk down the
street and be murdered by a man and and
what did I do to deserve that
why does it have to be a man you could
be murdered but no but I was talking
about that statistic when we're talking
about domestic violence it's it's men
because women my point my point is why
would I make a generalization about men
when it's not a huge percentage of
people that are dying oh okay so hands
have been like from domestic violence I
I well I think that's probably just the
difference in opinion because I think
one every three to four days is what two
a week I think that's why I mean you can
you can manipulate statistics to make
them sound alike it's a lot more
prevalent than it is but but when you
when you look at how many people if I
Googled right now how many people are in
the UK is that 60 million yeah 60
million people in the UK well at 110
that's not that's cool but then when you
put it down to one to every three to
four days that doesn't and that like I
said about one like a year and that
would have been just women but this is
what I'm saying get off this but this is
what I'm saying this is why because
there's a consequence for your action so
as men if you're gonna enable other men
and and whatnot then it's a repercussion
enable other men we just saw in a clip
where when people were attacked when he
was attacking a woman in public people
rushed to her yes how was that enabling
but well the thing is I I understand
that video the video is terrible but
that's just one incident you could film
that tomorrow and and there could be a
different reaction because I personally
have seen free incidences of domestic
violence with a woman being attacked and
I haven't seen any I was the one that
went to see them it was me so I I know
full well that that happens so I'm not
shocked by that video at all because I
don't know what people expect do you as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible